Hello, this is Dr. Kamikunner's section 7 of Eating Credit Climb.
This section we're going to be talking about how do you test for it.
Now the video here is going to be short because there's a lot in the written material of
this part.
Understand that there's a two-tier testing system for line that the centers of disease control
that's a little emblem down at the bottom right recommends.
It's an enzyme of uto assay and depending on if those are positive or negative, you will
forward from there.
Now I'm just giving total lip service to this, even in the book I'm giving lip service
because that's how I test for line.
So I use a special type of kinesiology for testing, that's very, very accurate.
If you don't have that access or somebody with that skill level to test for that, then
you have some choices.
You'll see what I recommend in the book.
That's not even my recommendation even if you have line disease.
If you have acute line, again, I'll go back to what I said in a previous presentation.
If you live in a high line area, you have all the symptoms of line and it's at a time
of line, so it's not in the middle of the winter, so then it's probably the flu.
If you have flu-like symptoms and it's in the summer and you are out working in the
yard, whether or not you even have a rash, you should probably treat it like a line.
So again, you have to go, you have to find a doctor.
So if you live in a line area, it's a good idea, you don't have line, it's a good idea
to find a doctor right now that will treat you based upon your symptom pattern, based upon
using wisdom and not having to depend on a test because the longer you have to wait,
even if that test was perfect, even if we had a perfect test which understand we do not.
Some reports say that up to 70% of additional live assays give a false negative.
So realistically, maybe it's 30%.
I don't care if it's 10% to leave 10% of the people thinking that they don't have line disease,
so they're not treated with an antibiotic which could have killed it in that window having
to suffer for 10 years with a chronic life and just ruin their life is malpractice in
my book.
Downright malpractice because you can't use your stink head and years of wisdom based upon
you actually try to get patients better, to get people better and use an antibiotic that
will knock it out of them.
There's lots of ways to heal the gut barrier if you damage it with an antibiotic.
Besides the fact that you're probably damaged and you've got barrier by eating genetically
modified foods and foods with all sorts of chemicals and then besides using an antibiotic
for 10 days, killing a live disease that could put you in a state that could kill you if
you don't treat it correctly.
So you're in a live area, just treat it that way.
The one test that I do recommend if you're going to get a lab test is the Igenics labs.
I believe they're on a california.
There's their symbol on this picture.
I have more information in the section of the book that you just downloaded.
So treat it like lime.
If it's in the chronic stage and you don't know it's lime, you can't get the test.
Unfortunately, the tests are a mutoglobulin test and they're not always positive.
After it's in its chronic stage.
So many times the mutoglobulins decrease after about six weeks and you could even have
a greater chance of showing a false negative.
All right, read this section and if you have any questions, contact our office.